(applaudissements)
- C'est une Ginette Reno
en grande forme qui a reçu
la Légion d'honneur,
le jour de ses 76 ans.
- J'aurais aimé que mes parents
soient toujours vivants
pour partager avec eux mon
incrédulité mais aussi ma joie.
- (en chantant): Ma chère
Ginette...
- Cette récompense pour
une carrière de plus de 60 ans
lui est remise six mois après
de graves ennuis de santé
où elle a failli mourir. mourir.
GINETTE RENO,
chanteuse
- Oui, par trois fois.
C'est pas le fun...
Je me rappelle, je suis
chez moi, puis là, je vais
tomber et je tombe. Puis là,
je fais : "Tu veux-tu...
Tu veux vraiment venir
me chercher tout de suite?"
J'ai dit : "Me semble que
j'ai encore d'autres choses
à faire avant, t'sais...
Viens pas me chercher
tout de suite." Et là,
je me suis accrochée après.
(♪ L'essentiel ♪)
- Essentielle, Ginette Reno
est bien plus qu'une chanson,
et ce sont des admirateurs
lantique qui ont milité
pour qu'elle obtienne
la Légion d'honneur.
- C'est gratifiant,
les trophées,
j'adore les médailles,
j'adore les prix.
Je les prends avec...
Des foisns un petit
peu mal à l'aise, mais je les
prends avec tout ce que je peux.
Comme quand j'étais petite!
J'aimais ça.
♪ L'essentiel,
c'est d'être aimé ♪
- En France, on l'a déjà
surnommé la "Édith Piaf
québécoise". Déjà très populaire
dans l'Hexagone, elle aurait
peut-être pu l'être encore
davantage, confie-t-elle.
- Je sais pas. Au a
commencé très fort. C'était...
Mais, je sais pas. Des fois,
je me pose la question, si
je me suis pas sabotée moi-même.
♪ C'est d'entrer dans son coeur
et n'en sortir jamais ♪
- Pendant qu'on la célèbre,
Ginette Reno a une pensée
pour son ami Guy Lafleur,
décédé la semaine dernière.
- Je viens troublée, j'en ai
pour un petit bout encore,
je le suis, là... C'est pas
facile, parce qu'on dit
que de l'autre côté,
c'est un Maurice Richard,
c'est une Ginette Reno,
c'est comme... c'est ça,
c'est du vrai monde...
♪ Mais moi je ne suis
qu'une chanson ♪
- Entre ses séances d'aqua gym
et de tai-chi, Ginette Reno
écrit son autobiographie
et, d'ici la fin de l'année,
elle pourrait lancer un disque
de chansons originales
et remonter sur scène.
- Non, j'ai vraiment...
Je vis comme si c'était
la dernière fois.
C'est le dernier temps.
C'est la dernière fois que
tu vas chanter, c'est celle-là
que tu vas chanter. Je suis
un peu arrangée comme ça, là.
♪ Je n'ai pas vu
passer le temps ♪
J'ai le feu sacré.
Le feu sacré.
C'est tout.
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪ Il nous glisse
entre les doigts